the new york jets they have had a crazy
couple of days
culminating in the signing of le'veon
bell reportedly four years 52 and a half
million it works out that just over 13
million a year 35 million guaranteed now
we don't know whether that's fully
guaranteed it's signing we don't know
how much of it is or isn't guaranteed
but it is a day look we're going to call
it like it is here this is a
disappointing contract in light of what
bell could have gotten in light of what
he should have gotten and the problem is
chris at the end of the day there was
only one team pursuing le'veon bell and
one of the big takeaways i had from
yesterday a lot of people in the media
got lied to by le'veon bell and his
agent all in the name of creating false
leverage that was going to be applied to
the jets and it didn't work whether it
was six teams being listed as being in
the mix for bell when there was only one
or whether it was the report yesterday
afternoon it was down to the ravens and
the jets when the ravens had never even
spoken
to agent adesa bukhari about le'veon
bell let me say that again the ravens
never even spoke to le'veon bell's agent
about signing le'veon bell but in this
crush to be first and especially now
right where oh i got to get this out i
got to get this out oh i got to be first
i got to beat this guy i got to beat
this person to the punch
we're not serving our purpose as
reporters in providing that bs filter
we're just running with whatever we get
that's right and not stopping to think
are we being lied to are we being
manipulated and a lot of people were
manipulated yesterday and it didn't work
the jets didn't get to 14.5 15 16 17
million a year at the end of the day
there was one team and that team paid
13.125 million per year over four years
that's a good deal for the jets
considering what it could have been or
should have been for le'veon bell yeah i
mean you're lucky you didn't make that
steak bet double or nothing with me
because you thought he was gonna get a
whole lot of money good job by you i had
a feeling well i had a feeling well
played there but uh i i mean i guess the
first thing i thought about this was
what was the biggest offer he got from
the pittsburgh steelers you know on a
yearly basis that that that that is the
first thing i thought of second thing i
thought of is yes uh obviously le'veon
bell they fabricated some of the
interest within them but at the same
time did they not think that the new
york jets could call other teams they
don't need to ask details but they can
just go are you guys pursuing le'veon
bell no oh okay so that of course i i
would think took le'veon bell's leverage
away to a degree because i would think
the jets did make those calls to figure
out if there was really somebody they
were competing with um but
let me tell you this chris
once i started hearing in the afternoon
that the ravens weren't in it and were
never in it i i had to be sure
that that was true before i would say it
because i thought maybe there's some
next level stuff going on here where the
ravens are trying to scare off the jets
or get the jets to lowball le'veon bell
thinking there is no interest from the
ravens and then the ravens swoop in and
get him so i i spent an extra half hour
once i became aware that the ravens
weren't in it i took another half hour
to be damn sure that that was accurate
before i put it out there even though
hey you got to be first got to get it
out there i you know these things look
this is all cloak and dagger this is
all's fair in love war and football and
if i'm the jets if i'm calling a team
that may be in it for le'veon bell how
do i trust what i'm getting because if
they want le'veon bell they'd love
nothing more than to throw a wrench in
my effort to get le'veon bell yeah well
listen this is business and sometimes
people pull some dirty tricks in
business so you know again i i think you
know that goes on it's unfortunate but
you and i have talked about this the
last three days you got to be careful
about who you listen to what you listen
to because it's all about personal
agenda and how they could further it
from there either way i think i am
surprised by the total number i thought
he would one-up a todd gurley but the
biggest thing is this just just because
he didn't you know beat todd gurley in
yearly average salary or total number
altogether the guaranteed money was
really one of the big the big fights
with the pittsburgh steelers and he's
getting 35 million dollars guaranteed so
i think at the end of the day that's
what he was looking for he was looking
for security in case somebody hog tied
him again as they were tackling him like
vontez burfek did a few years ago and
blew out his leg he needs that knowing
gosh if that happens again that might be
an end of my career so from that
standpoint i'm sure he's very happy and
this may be another area where
what we're told may not be what's real
and the details will come in later today
and into tomorrow as to what these deals
really are we'll break them down to pro
footballtalk.com but that guaranteed
money component was important because
the steelers refused to have guaranteed
money beyond the first year of a
contract that's just the way they do
things we know the jets will do it
differently chris because with darrell
rivas a few years ago first year salary
fully guaranteed second year salary
fully guaranteed and 6 million in the
third year was fully guaranteed now
again the devil will be in the details
and i can't wait to see what the details
of this contract are because there's a
chance it's not 52 and a half million
over four years there's a chance it's
not 35 million guaranteed or there's
little terms in there that aren't
apparent that could make this thing not
quite what it seems but you know look
the the big takeaway for me and and
maybe the todd gurley injury was a
factor sure whatever it is that's going
on with todd gurley right but
to to be a one of the best running backs
in football if not the best to get to
the open market unrestricted and to not
set the high water mark at your own
position that's a stunner that's a shock
yeah it's a shocker but you know i i do
think that the todd gurley thing had to
play into this a little bit i'm cert i'm
sure the jets and teams would have used
that or used that against le'veon bell
hey todd gurley's younger than le'veon
bell you know todd gurley's more
explosive he's more of a home run hitter
that way too so i think they a lot of
teams probably looked at and said wait
todd gurley's the guy we've been talking
about maybe being mvp of football the
last two years and i know we got to
forget that what happened at the end of
last year and all that but that's what
his talent was looked at as one of the
most explosive home run hitting
linebackers uh running backs in football
and le'veon bell as awesome as he is i
don't think he's in that class in in
that way as far as just an absolute game
breaker he's an awesome player don't get
me wrong i'm not trying to say that but
i think that probably played a factor
into it and them going look and there's
todd gurley who had a knee injury a few
years ago just like you did le'veon bell
and now he's having problems with it
again that scares the hell out of us and
i'm sure all of those things were used
as a little bit of a leverage just to
lower that number a tad bit
especially when you can draft running
backs and pay them peanuts yeah
comparison right to the top of the
market that's part of the reality of
this rookie wage scale and it's hurting
veteran players and bell is the latest
victim of this reality that either
you're the colts and you have marlon
mack at 480 000 this year or you can go
out and draft a marlin mackin round
three four
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports